[Music]
all right let's go out to Naples and
talk to Iris what's up
Iris hello Dr John thank you for taking
my call of course thanks for calling
what's up oh my God I'm so
excited bring it no nothing much um just
trying to figure it out how to do this
mom life in this crazy world I'm not a
mom so I'll just be guessing but go for
it I'm sure you have some good
insights so uh sorry for my accent H hey
hold on never ever apologize for your
accent ever it's beautiful oh no anyways
hold on no no never apologize for your
the way you talk it's
beautiful it adds color to the
world you
promise absolutely not but
okay
ah been battling for 15 years and still
there but anyways thank you for your
words I appreciate that be it's
beautiful it's beautiful all right go
forward so how do I help my 12-year-old
boy make relation you know relationships
with others friends he's got no friends
uh but I feel it's kind of my fault
because I've been always telling him
that like um people are evil and don't
trust people and stay away from mink
kids and
why I don't know why' you tell him that
cuz it's the truth
though for 12y old well he got bullied a
while back and I'm trying to like help
him not to fail fall for it like I feel
like if kids find him friendship or
friend friendly they're going to just
take more advantage of him I don't know
so here's an example of of what you did
okay and you know know you listen to the
show before yes you know I love you and
I'm going to be real honest with you
both at the same time cool bring it yeah
okay what you did was you went into the
gym and you saw your your 12-year-old
boys probably 10 or 11 at the time
lifting weights and you saw that they
were heavy and he was
struggling so instead of getting behind
the bar and helping spot him and putting
a couple of fingers underneath the bar
and helping him lift mhm you took all
the weight off the bar and then you hung
the bar up and you said never lift again
again because that's too
heavy and so he got bullied and then Mom
said hey you can't ever handle this
you're always going to be subjected to
people taking advantage of you your best
option for life is to
hide you see what I'm saying SP on
exactly how I feel okay you have to
throw that nonsense into reverse on the
highway like
today okay cuz his body body is going to
respond to Mom he's going to absorb the
tension of the adults in his
life and he's going to learn others
aren't safe and the problem is our
bodies use other people like oxygen you
cannot do life without them I know and
that's where I find myself at the you
know the fork of like he needs to make
friendships and relationships and then
now he's not you need friendships and
relationships first oh true
you you Iris all right how do you know
these things here's the path forward
it's a simple path and it's going to be
the worst you
ready you have to take him out to dinner
is his dad in the picture yes yes what
does Dad think about all
this you think I'm
crazy for
what for even I don't know for
even ah I don't know he's we're very
different tell me
how I mean I don't he's he's a man so he
am
world I have a 13-year-old little boy I
want him to have a bunch of friends a
whole bunch of wackadoo different
friends that tell him all kind of crazy
things and they get into hij Jinks
together yeah and he does my husband
he's he's got friends he plays baseball
with them and okay uh but I I don't see
myself doing those kind of
things okay you for the sake of your son
you are now
I gotta yeah so the path forward is you
Mom you take him out to a special meal
just the two of
you and let him
know I've got to talk to you about
something serious and
special and he'll go oh geez here we go
again mom and I want you to say magic
words what he says I know because you've
been doing it his whole life you've been
lecturing him telling him that things
are scary and people are awful and
things are terrible and and and and and
don't talk like that and be weary of
your accent people are going to make fun
of you and they're going to look right
you've been telling that his whole
life 100% And I feel all full body okay
cool and now it's time to change you
cannot change one second of what
happened from right now in into the past
but you can change everything about what
comes
next I want you to take him out I want
you to look him across the table I want
you to hold both of his hands and he's
going to be all weird about him like Mom
and say no hold my hands and I want you
to say these magic words I was
wrong I was
wrong I was scared for somebody to hurt
my little boy
again and out of my own fear I cast it
on
you and I taught you to be afraid of the
world are you going to get hurt in the
world yes but is the path forward to
hide from the world no it's to become
strong and confident in the face of
what's
coming and those are two different
things okay that's number one and he's
going to say okay thanks Mom fine fine
fine and I want you to make a commitment
to yourself for the next I don't know 90
days three months you want to get weird
let's get weird you Iris have to invite
adult friends to your house once a week
for the next 90 days oh your son has to
see you have friends yep and you can't
be all awkward about
it and I know you're going to be because
I I'm super
awkward yeah I read your book about it
and I've been trying to and it's like
how do I even say all the people to
let's move my friend let's move him off
the side why do you think you're not
worth having friends I don't know no I
don't even think he that it's I I find
hard time connecting
why with others like I'm I maybe have a
standard and I need to bring it down a
not no that's not it from thinking what
do you like what do you mean what's your
standard I don't know I rather I want to
do religion but I'm Christian and i'
rather you just be surrounded by people
that think around the same
and kind of like that but it's not even
that I don't know I get that I'm
Christian too and some of my best
friends on planet Earth don't believe in
anything and that's okay maybe that's
what I'm struggling with of course it's
okay they're still great moms and dads
okay there's they're amazing parents we
just we just disagree and I love that
and I especially here's what I
especially love I love my son and my
daughter around people who do Church
different than us who do no church at
all who think differently than us I love
them around those great people while
they're in my home because while they're
in my home they're going to ask
me when they leave my home they're going
to run into these people all over the
place and two things happen number one
they go to Google instead of me and so
I'm turning over virtue I'm turning over
development I'm turning over value
creation to the
internet when I had 18 years of my own
home that's number one number two your
kids are going to run into people who
love differently than they do look
differently than they do speak different
languages than they do do religion
differently than they do and they're
going to find they're amazing people and
they're fun and they have great values
and they're great parents and then
they're going to think my mom was lying
to me the whole time I wonder what else
she was lying to me about yeah right
yeah and so I'm trying to create a
bubble and that's right working out it
never works
out now when you're a four or fiveyear
old fine bubbles are good
but as when your kid gets to be
12 yeah he's got to have a bunch of
knuckleheaded buddies he's running
around doing stuff
with right yep and how old are you right
now 34 you need that
too you need that
too and here's the thing if you think
hold if you think because of your
particular
religion that you are above people you
need to reimagine your religion no no
it's not that I I know but you said I
need to lower my
standard and so you my my my own like I
don't even know what I meant I don't
know yeah but it's true so here's your
homework you've got to go make friends
your and you have to do it where your
kid can see it or hey you're on your own
for dinner tonight honey because I'm
going to hang out with my girlfriends
we're going to have fun what you
yes h husband son yall are on your own
and by the way son go with Dad and watch
him play baseball not to watch him play
baseball does he do that they do they go
okay yeah they take he takes him
everywhere that's the beauty of them too
they they have a beautiful relationship
awesome well he's getting to watch his
dad have friends which is good
yeah that's fantastic and then here's
the other thing you have to start
inviting other 12y olds 11y olds 13 year
olds into your house
okay and let it roll yeah obviously keep
him safe obviously don't have him around
violent or evil
Knuckleheads it's not like I'm ald kind
of freak clean freak so I'll I'll work
on it you're a clean freak or he is oh I
am so that's probably why we don't do
anything in the house and everything
okay there was one uh there was one
group recently that uh a couple that
similarly So at their homework
assignment it's actually a a show that
we film that's going to be coming out in
a few weeks I one of their homework
assignments was they had to have a
different couple over every week and
they had to mess up one thing in their
living room leave a basket of laundry
out leave plates with food on them in
the
sink because for some reason you've told
your you've taught yourself or somebody
taught you and you believe it that your
only value is being clean that's right
yep and let me tell you something I can
tell you by just this phone call you're
probably pretty hilarious aren't
you I can be yes I bet you're really
funny and I bet you're super hilariously
opinionated about things right yep how
do you know these things without even
metting me before because I can hear it
in I can hear how you're communicating
with me I would like to hang out with
you are you an amazing
cook yep y I think so I would
love to sit at your table and eat and
just completely get into arguments about
politics with you I would love that cuz
cuz I bet you're hilarious about it and
I bet you get so mad and then 13 seconds
later we're friends again yep yes why
would you rob your neighbors of how
awesome you
are I don't
know can I ask you a hard hard question
that's kind of mean go for
it when your husband and son are gone
and the dishes are all clean and
everything's
spotless do you have that feeling of
loneliness inside
every time every
time you're worth having friends and for
God's sakes don't give that pit in your
stomach to your son too I know and
that's why I'm calling that's why I I I
knew you had an
answer here's the thing I I'm saying
this because I love you he is very very
vulnerable right now here's why yeah
he's gonna
crave desperately like a drug
friendships in other people
and because he thinks there's something
wrong with
him so much so that he was so weak that
it had to be withdrawn from Human
contact because his mom didn't come in
and say oh you can't lift this we're
putting more weight on the bar and we're
going to do this every day until you get
strong he's going to gravitate towards
kids that will pray on him even
more and that's my fear right so it
created the thing the very thing were
the most scared of yeah right and so he
might need to go to counseling for a bit
and learn some skills on how to deal
with bullies okay he might need a mom
that's like you can do anything and who
lets him try so that he's got able to
stand up and when that bully says that's
a stupid shirt you he can go man you got
the best shirt in on in school and the
bully doesn't know what he's uh what
what what right you can teach him some
of those skills or better yet his
friends can he can continue to go play
with with his dad but at the end of the
day he's going to look with a side eye
at his
mom and he's going to see her having
friends and he's going to see her not
carrying if there's an extra dish in the
sink because she's got a group of women
over and they're being loud and silly
and
arguing and he's going to have a couple
of knuckleheaded 12-year-olds running
around in the backyard and and and why
because y'all are worth relationships
you're worth friendships you're worth
all of it
and we're not going to hang our head in
shame could we have done this
differently yes and are you a pretty
amazing mom because you caught yourself
and you want to do something different
ABS freak lutely I love you for it Iris
I'm so proud of
you let's have that lunch that breakfast
that dinner today tomorrow I'm sorry I
cast my loneliness onto you and I was
wrong those kids that were ugly to you
when you were six and seven and eight
and nine were were done done
running because you're my son and you
should throw your head back shoulders
back head held high cuz you're my
son hang on the line I'm going to send
you all the questions for humans for the
for uh kids parents friends teens I'm
gonna send them all of them and that
would be a good Gateway for you and him
to start talking and I'm G to send you
the grown-up ones too I'm G send you all
the decks all of them I think we got
like 20 of them man I'm going to send
the whole truckload and you can use them
with your friends when you're sitting
there feeling your heart starts to beat
fast like oh my is my house clean enough
I don't know you're going to have some
conversation starters and by the way I
Ed them this morning with my 13-year-old
at our breakfast this morning and he was
kind of annoyed by him he's like Dad I
just want to sit here nope we're doing
it we're talking then we got into some
good
conversations I'm gonna send them all to
you to take away that like I don't know
what to do next I got you I got you
questions for
humans I'm proud of you for making a
change but you got to go make the change
you're worth it so is
he